Say you've designed your robot, now you want to put a skin over his frame to
make him look more lifelike and infiltrate the humans, become more accepted by
humanity. A robot model typically has a few rigid elements that do not change
over time, such as a forearm and an upper arm. At the joint the objects are
clearly separate. That's where you'd like to put skin. One simple solution is
to just put some triangles connecting the two rigid pieces, sort of like a
cylinder. As the joint bends, these triangles deform and stretch, keeping the
two arm pieces attached. This doesn't look very good as the more the arm bends,
the more the joint flattens out. What we'd prefer is something more like a
flexible tube that bends, but mostly keeps its shape. Say we now add such a
joint, with three cylinders, one after the other. The challenge now is how to
move these cylinder vertices as the joint bends. The basic solution is
surprisingly simple. Each vertex is assigned a weight. This weight is how much
each rigid part's position affects the vertex. The top and bottom of the tube
still stays connected to its rigid body part, so that body part's influence has
a weight of 1. For vertices closer to the forearm, the weight is say, 2 3rds
forearm, 1 3rds upper arm. This modeling process of adding polygons and
assigning weights is called skinning, or sometimes vertex blending. The rigid
parts of the model are defined by bones. These bones are like a skeleton, so
this whole area is sometimes called skeletal animation. As a bone moves, the
skin is influenced by the bone's transform times its weight. Specifically,
let's look at this one vertex on the skin that's near the forearm. The vertex
location is transformed twice. Once with respect to the forearm, and once with
respect to the upper arm. These two transformed locations are then multiplied
by their corresponding weights, giving the interpolated point between them. The
basic algorithm works fairly well, but can have problems. For example, in the
inner part of the elbow, the points may bend inwards in an unconvincing way. In
practice, the vertex can be influenced by more than two bones. The bones and
weights are something the person modeling decides, and the weights always add
up to 1. These characters were exported from Valve's Team Fortress 2 game and
animated with Three.js' skinning class called skinned mesh. Skinning is well
suited to the GPU, as the vertex shader can transform plates multiple times and
add together the weighted locations. There are more elaborate algorithms that
give better results, but for interactive rendering in particular, skinning is
the mainstay.